there were thousands of girls 12 and 13
years old who made tapes across the
country and I saw several hundred of the
tapes and I personally interviewed at
least a hundred girls and there came a
time when I thought we're not going to
be able to make this film with a twelve
or thirteen year old girl it was
impossible for a lot of reasons not
least of which was what was this going
to do to a child after performing an
experience like that and I remember
sitting in my office at Warner Brothers
the Warner Brothers by the way was at
666 Fifth Avenue which is an address
that still exists and the building is
owned by Jared Kushner so process that
process this and I remember I had my
head in my hands and I was thinking
we're going to have to try and find some
16 or 15 year old girls who look younger
who can do this
when my assistant buzzed me and said
there's a woman out here named Eleanor
Blair and she's brought her daughter she
doesn't have an appointment would you
see her and I said why not
the second Linda Blair walked in the
door I knew it was her I just knew it
because I don't know how many of you
believe in God but those of us who have
made films and had some success
certainly believe in the movie God and I
believe it was the movie God that
brought Ellen Burstyn and Linda Blair to
the film so I asked her if she knew
anything about the Exorcist book and she
said oh yes I read it I said you read
this book yeah I said what's it about
she said it's about a little girl that
gets possessed by the devil and does a
whole bunch of bad things and I said
well like what and she said well she
hits her mother across the face
and she pushes a man out of her bedroom
window and she masturbates with a
crucifix and I looked at her mother who
was still smiling
and so I got in touch with Ellen and we
tested her and Ellen worked with her
like a mother she not only Linda's
mother who passed away
was wonderful but Ellen became a
surrogate mother to Linda on the set and
the reason that Linda is so damn good in
this picture is because Ellen worked
with her and talked to her and embraced
her and imparted all the incredible
knowledge that she has as an actress my
favorite images of Linda is in the
makeup room it took her hours every day
to get in that horrible makeup and so
there was a television behind her and
she she would be facing the mirror and
this horrible face would be put on her
but she's watching cartoons on the TV